hello and congratulations jay
hi barry nice to meet you thank you very
much so i have a feeling this is
probably going to be the thing that most
are wondering about after seeing the
movie
does this really happen to people how
much truth is there
in the operation that marla's running uh
in mother's operation a lot of it
happens unfortunately it's uh
it's true true to life and the fact that
there are lots of
these predatory guardians who do prey on
vulnerable and elderly people and sort
of
entrap them in these guardianships and
uh basically sort of strip their life
apart
it's uh the true life stories of it uh
really quite harrowing and horrifying
um so unfortunately yeah it does it does
happen
is there any particular true detail you
learned about that kind of scenario
while you were prepping for this that
maybe you didn't have the screen time to
include in the movie that you wanted to
not really i mean the sort of the aim of
the movie wasn't really to do an expose
on this
on this uh scam it was more to you know
show this scam and show how it's sort of
like an example of what
what kind of happens in a in a in a
world which is
sort of focused on like um on success
and on efficiency you know and on
trusting people that you already know
you know so like the judge
works with marla all the time so like
likes her and understands her and
trusts her in a way that he doesn't know
the family member and doesn't trust them
and family members emotional
whereas marla's not she's efficient and
and very well put together i mean
one thing i we spoke about um while
we're making the film i spoke to
rosamund about
which maybe you know you sort of get a
sense of it but it didn't really make
the final film which is
if you met mother in real life and like
i say at a party or something you'd like
just think well she's like
very attractive or even put together
well-dressed you know she seems to have
a great relationship caring relationship
with her
girlfriend and she you know she's got
great taste i mean her office is
beautiful and she's kind of smart and
you know she seems she seems really um
really great person and then you'd ask
her what do you do for a living and she
goes well you know i take care of
elderly people and you think this
this lady is great she's a saint but you
know part of that you know that thing of
like
people looking to the world as if
they're like good people who do
good things but actually there's lots of
bad things underneath the hood i think
is something that is very true of that
world and true of lots of different
people in
positions of authority who get away with
a lot because people just trust them
because they're
oh they're the guy that we know you know
so there's that element that we didn't
quite make into the film but
i think is very true in that case then
on the flip side of it
what drew you to having you know this
protagonist that's doing a bad
thing having her go up against someone
or at least
target someone who is also doing a bad
thing
rather than having made jennifer a you
know a
more traditional innocent party
i mean i think jennifer's innocent of
whatever
you know marla's doing to her she
doesn't deserve that i don't think
anybody deserves that i don't think uh
you know whatever you done in your life
you don't deserve bad things to happen
to you
kind of by a con person but i think um
marla's character and these characters
in real life sort of struck me as being
a little bit like gangsters you know
they come in and they they steal
something
under false pretenses and then they sort
of strip it for parts and then
you know pump all the money out of it as
they can you know when they've got
assets they
they use those assets and overcharge and
overcharge another charge and when they
run out of those assets and assets and
they get put onto
you know sort of government money they
then just store them in like the worst
care home they sort of run through their
money fast as possible and store them in
the worst care home and just forget
about them just park them and then move
on to the next one
that felt almost like you know a
gangster's operation
and so the idea of taking somebody who's
basically um
a legal gangster because there's not
really anything she's doing that's
totally against the law she's
overcharging people but she's sort of
exposing loopholes in the law running up
against somebody who
is a gangster and like is on the other
side of the law felt
quite interesting and like because he
has like violence and ruthlessness
and like criminality on his side where
she is on the right side of the law and
how different are they so
having this sort of yin and yang of like
of immorality
pitted against each other and seeing put
them in sort of like a death match of
who's going to give up first
seemed uh like a bit of a delicious
prospect
that it was uh before i get kicked out
of here i did want to ask you more of a
broader career question because
i saw alice creed at tribeca and i've
been following your work ever since
and i know that jumping from alice creed
to the fifth wave was a big step up as
far as you know scope and scale goes but
of course that also comes with
higher risk and expectations and maybe
studio involvement so
how did the reception to that one wind
up
influencing the next project you wanted
to do i mean i think it was it was less
the reception the more of my experience
of it
i mean on alice creed i'd written it and
so i was totally across the script and
was sort of
as the writer and director of it i uh i
sort of had the
the parent authority because it was on a
lower budget to make the film i wanted
to make and just sort of necessarily as
like a smaller filmmaker going to a big
studio
uh i didn't have the the authority or
the power that i had on the smaller film
and you know that's that would happen to
any filmmaker in any studio i think of a
similar sort of jump up and some sort of
you know um similar material that's
going to be released in every cinema
in the world you know so i think what
that did is sort of
solidify in my head that the thing that
i really like to do
is to write the scripts and have can
have like authority over the script and
then move forward and direct it that way
it feels like the same the same job to
me whereas i didn't have that same job
on the fifth wave so
although i learned a huge amount from
making the fifth wave um
as you will do is like going to like a
big budget
film school but getting paid for it you
know what i mean and some brilliant
actors i work in some brilliant
people on the crew who i worked with i
think that i found it much more
satisfying to
to have written and directed so coming
back and like you know
10 years after i agreed to make i care a
lot it felt much more of
you know familiar of like you know the
material being
more me and i think that was more
rewarding in the end ten years after i
still quite like when you write and
direct
a movie so huge congratulations on this
i absolutely loved it
thank you barry thank you